Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is. 2192. David P here
is a caller saying, you know.
You're still a shill, but you're the best shill.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. Is this Brad from
Bloomington, Indiana?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 5: I just want to say, I always thought
of you as a shill for the past four years.
Right. I got to say. Nothing's changed. But
I think that you're. The best show out there.
Speaker 1: That's nice.
Speaker 5: You really hit it every day.
You're getting better at it. Sorry, I the later.
Speaker 1: Okay. So, um, you know, the funny thing
about this is I think a lot of the people using
the word shell don't really know what it means.
Like, for me, the idea of shell is you are some
kind of an accomplice of someone who is doing
something bad and maybe you're even a useful idiot
and that you don't realize that you're doing it.
Or maybe you do. Yeah, I don't know. All the shell
stuff. It's either people think I'm a shill for
the Democratic Party despite not being a Democrat
and saying so many times, I don't care about the
Democratic Party. The Democratic Party is almost
just like a corporation whose priority is to
perpetuate its own existence. If the Democrats are
the better candidate, I'll vote for the Democrat.
I'll support and support the Democrat. But I don't
really care about the Democratic Party. Some say
that I am a shill for a socialism or communism.
And of course I'm neither a socialist nor a
communist, so that one doesn't really make a ton
of sense. It's all very weird, but I don't even
know if they know what it means to be a shell. But
if you're going to be a shill, I'd rather be the
best. And so I'll accept the compliment. I guess
we have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 3: The bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Alex Jones is really wound
up about today's bonus show because Russia
is no longer in full control of any of the
four so-called annexed Ukrainian provinces.
I don't think Alex Jones is happy about that.
We're also going to talk about the Supreme Court
rejecting a gun rights challenge to the banning
of bump stocks. This is triggering a lot of
the more guns in more places. Folks, I guess
I would say. And Kim, is it pronounced card de?
This is not someone I'm familiar with. She has
been charged by the. That's a joke, by the way.
She has been charged by the FCC for unlawfully
touting a cryptocurrency scam on her Instagram
account. It is explosive and it is wild, wild
stuff. All of these stories and more hyperbole
and conjecture. On today's bonus show when I'm
joined by producer Pat. Get instant access to
the bonus show and I do mean instant. By either
signing up it join Pacman dot com or becoming a
patron at Patria CNN.com slash David Pakman show.
Both are options to immediately get you access
to the bonus. Joe. I hope to see you there.